sophie évite à maurepas elle compose
textes et mélodies depuis plusieurs
années et son tour d'autres musiciens
pour former le groupe lilly sofa
alexandre de maurepas s'occupe des
arrangements franck originaire de
trappes joue de la guitare
quant à givet également des yvelines il
est percussionniste et s'intéresse aux
beaux draps un instrument irlandais
c'est un peu dur pop folk le côté folk
pour le les guitares acoustiques la
référence à un instrument 5 et la vielle
à roue et puis sinon ça reste ça reste
pop c'est de la chanson c'est assez
frais la chanson goldilocks qui signifie
boucle d'or en français s'inspire
directement du compte je repensais à ce
conte de montclos d'or de closer et les
trois ours l'attitude trouve pas bien sa
place entre entre le père la mère et
l'enfant
et puis puis en fait en me baladant il y
avait un rythme qui venait
c'est aussi pour ça que cette chanson
est uniquement rythmique et voix je
voyais pas du tout une musique dessus je
vois les oncles ide dans ton coeur
humain ce qui me le tout les ombres
c'était c'est une façon de les arts en
fête qui est venue suite à une sorte de
rêve au cauchemar
j'avais j'avais ce light motif les
ombres les ombres qui me trottait dans
la tête
et puis un jour j'étais un peu énervé je
jouais avec un peu fou de rage sans trop
faire attention à la technique il y
avait des harmoniques qui venait et
petit à petit à se rivent un peu un peu
d'un peu de tellurique un peu aussi très
cyclique qui venait et puis de les
paroles sont reçus lily sofa se produira
vendredi 26 octobre à saint rémy les
chevreuse au tâtre caf art
l'album du groupe n'est pas encore
commercialisé mais sophie 2 propose au
public pour de ses concerts qui sur
internet